we do have a guest that is definitely
not on his first victory that is Fabiano
caruana Fabiano congratulations with the
black pieces a big important result how
do you feel and how did you strategize
this game
I played a very random line which I
knew a little bit I mean I didn't really
know much I didn't know how to prepare
this opening because elshon isn't really
an E4 player but he was playing in this
tournament so I figured he has some idea
in mind
uh but I he had no games in this line so
I just decided to play it without were
you trying to get a fighting game out of
the opening yeah I mean I I think it's a
very risky opening choice
and I didn't know what to do after
Bishop G3 I knew it was some sort of
line I just didn't know like I thought
Knight F6 he'll take and play E5 and get
a slightly better position exactly yeah
and I didn't really feel like going for
something which he knows where it's a
tiny bit better for it
so I decided to get creative which um
was certainly not good
not good okay I mean I I don't imagine
that uh
playing Bishop B7 Bishop D7 is very good
for black
but then he shocked me I mean Bishop G4
I was a
and I think this one was the uh I mean
I thought white is slightly better with
some kind of Castle short or something
95 yeah something along those lines but
black has a solid position
um and then Bishop G4 nearly loses on
the spot
because after take H5 only move is Queen
H3 and if G5 only moves F3 not to lose
the queen
um of course that's the queen not that
Bishop well I guess you can play Bishop
H4 if you really want to yeah but uh if
you don't want to lose material F3 is so
it's it's I understood he was trying to
trade the Bishops at any cost but to put
the queen on H3 and take so much time
doing so it felt like the very very
risky and incorrect Choice and then I
thought it was completely unclear
later on I mean it was a very
complicated position
how would you come up with this plan
Bishop G5 Rook to H6 well Bishop G5 is
to stop long Castle it's pretty simple
uh his his King on the king side is a
little bit vulnerable
um because the queen is there it's all
his pieces are sort of crowded around
together and he can't move the queen if
he would get cast along King B1 I think
he would have a fine position to be one
yeah he could later Play Bishop 2 and G3
and with the King on uh G1 you never
want to play G3
so I was happy to get the king there and
what about Rook to H6 what was the idea
behind it uh sorry okay if we go back a
move and say he I play Knight F6 instead
then F4 and I wasn't sure about this I
saw in various moves here like Knight H7
some crazy stuff fg5 Knight G5 Queen G4
HG Queen G3
I didn't want to allow this because it
felt a bit easier to play for white he
plays Rook D1 and then he gets all the
files
um although maybe it's also kind of
unclear uh so F4 I just didn't want to
allow
so Rook H6 is forcing the bishop back
and now he no longer achieves F4 so
easily it's still one of his main ideas
to get F4 even at the cost of a pawn
sometimes
um so I think what we did was normal
Rook D1 Queen C7 Knight C1
uh A3 very questionable I thought
um I think that was yeah the engine was
saying as well so instead of A3 I was
thinking
um yeah I was thinking like Knight one
E2 and then I'll probably play either 97
or King G8 some move like that
let's say King G8 and he can play A3
it's exactly the same plan but now I
didn't have this Knight A5 resourceless
I play like 97. but here he just has B3
and the Knight on C3 is protected so
let's say 97 Rook D3 some kind of Rook
d8 Rook I like this type of position
um it just felt equal to me yeah I
didn't see what I'm doing I also didn't
see what he's doing I would be a bit
more comfortable with black because I
really think white has like no ideas
here you can move the knight from C3 you
can't move the knight from E2 and your
Rooks are very nice but
but also and it's pretty difficult to
get the queen back in into place well
yeah like the only way is F4 at some
point which comes at the cost of a pawn
so it's not easy at all but still black
has to find some sort of idea here yeah
so A3 I I thought was very very slow and
I took the chance to play Knight A5
um yeah and here I I thought like 94 is
a huge mistake yep I thought like F4 was
very unclear ef4
um and yeah Bishop 493 so uh so Queen F5
and I was wondering about this Rook H5
here
Knight F4 G6 I thought Queen G6
and uh if FG then 96 and Knight C7
yeah
um so it seems to be so I wasn't sure
Rook H5 or Rook G6 it was but I decided
I'll I'll take that choice because I'm
no longer risking uh and I'll just like
let's say Knight F4 take take
um and in type B2 then uh Queen D6 which
I guess is still kind of better for
black but
I mean I wasn't worried you know it's
clear that I'm the only one pressing
here but I still thought the position
was quite unclear and after this Knight
C4 night before I wasn't sure Queen seed
or Knight B2 I mean queen C8 I think it
was the right decision to get into this
yeah it looked very practical but then I
messed it up later I thought I I already
thought the game's over
at what point and then like yeah I just
thought like after A5 because after A5
if he doesn't play Knight A2 which I
thought was a good try
um yep that let's say he plays an id5
the problem for him is like take take
Knight to E3
he has to take or he loses an exchange
King H1 Rook C2 Rook A5
and he's getting mated
um yeah like Rook G6 there's still Rook
A8 King E7 Knight C3
but I think that even if I play like
King D7 here or something yeah 95 Bishop
D4 yeah he's just getting made it slowly
so so this is what I thought might
happen but instead he went for this uh
very nice exchange stack I mean it's a
good practical chance probably the only
chance yeah he has
I don't know like yeah I definitely
messed up but I wasn't sure how to play
this I mean
and then Bishop d8 it's like an
extraordinary opportunity no not not
here but a movie four instead of Rook D3
we were talking about this after the
game uh the difference is that if um B5
now Bishop F6 GF Knight D5
uh he attacks the bishop so there's no
Rook C2 yep it's on about 97 so much but
the bishop is also attacked so if he had
done this I mean I'm still better but uh
but really messed it up not the
enthusiastic will be shot to d8 yeah
yeah so this was a was very sloppy to
allow this uh but he did it the move
later when it was very
um
where it was just a move too late
Bobby's still seven rounds to go but
you're extending your lead uh at the top
how are you feeling about your chances
right now or are you even thinking about
that championship
no well how can I play it without
thinking about it I mean I'm I'm quite
happy so far it's been going well uh
I can't say that my games are brilliant
but still the results are very good
um I was even happy with like my game
yesterday not yesterday but the day
before against Wesley because I didn't
have many ambitions
um but still I post him some serious
issues I thought and uh he was very
close to getting in trouble
so it felt like even if I'm not getting
anything out of the opening I'm still
able to pose my opponent some problems
which is a good sign
um and other players are a little bit
uneven so far but we'll see it's still a
long way to go guys during the
conversation yeah I have a question to
Fabi I mean Fabiana you're local here
you know we know that you live not far
away from the club and these days
especially that U.S championships are
happening I recognize More Often by
people on the streets and like how is
your life these days
well I I got recognized but I can't say
it's because of me
I think it's more because of Hans I mean
I get stopped off and then uh asked
about Beats
it happens more often than I'd I'd like
to to admit
um but yeah it seems like chess is
pretty popular these days sometimes
people notice me because I'm uh I guess
a local player but more often than not
it's uh
it's about the current the current
ongoing situation yeah that's what I
thought a quick question for you Fabi uh
in this U.S championships we're seeing a
lot of draws very very very tough hard
to win games and then suddenly
it's like you know the sky's open and
you're you're winning game after game
how does that happen what what what what
what makes uh sudden a rampage of
Victories when everybody's having a
heart's log
well I think a lot of his circumstance
you know some tournaments even if you're
not playing poorly you just don't get a
chance some tournaments uh everyone's
giving giving things to you so it's just
important to get those those victories
at the right moment those opportunities
at the right moment
um but yeah chess is very much like that
that sometimes you go a long period
without
any opportunities with your opponents
playing brilliantly and not giving you
any chances and sometimes
um very strong players collapse for
unexpected reasons so um that's just the
way chess is it it balances out in the
end but uh but that can explain the
current you know uh pot streaks that
people have or or collapses that people
have
um it's not always in your hands I mean
you you
try to control it as much as you can but
very often
um I mean you still need help from your
opponent to win games if your opponents
never make mistakes then then you'll
never win a game so it's uh that's
that's just how it is
very good luck yes absolutely uh good
luck uh turning our attention to the
game of